prenda tutti ragazzi i primi aiuti a
questo nuovo video oggi vi parlo di di
un mio punto debole nel settore
rassicurarvi dicendovi che sono riuscito
finalmente a fare la carta d'identità me
l'hanno data ed elettronica quindi
bellissimo e vi faccio vedere la foto
ragazzi è bellissimo perché sembra la
foto sono veramente un gran figo ragazze
quando volete mischiate in direct riesce
perché sembra tipo la tessera dei
pokémon c'è questa cosa qua che il peso
delle palestre bellissimo sono proprio
allenatore provetto di nuovo la carta
d'identità adesso non vedo l'ora di
perderla
giochiamo che parliamo un po oggi
ragazzi voglio raccontarvi di situazione
della mia vita molto molto molto triste
e finalmente arrivato il momento in cui
ne parlò allora ragazzi questa parte
triste della verità comincia nel 2013
barra 2014 con 2013 quando una persona
compie 18 anni ha prima cosa che fece in
mente è la patente finalmente si guida
se vi se vai in macchina che bello mamma
mia
sapessi come bb spiego allora il
problema è stato questo io quando andavo
a scuola non andavo a scuola e facevo
youtube capito facevo youtube
quindi io avevo il mio canale la tener
su un video al giorno e avevo lo studio
di offrirne losco che il tratto non era
neanche una scuola facile perché dicono
tutti gli istituti tecnici sono scuole
facili barbu gas ma fallo dubbio mio
istituto tecnicamente che veramente
difficile soprattutto sulle materie
matematiche quindi studia un sacco
dovevo fare i video già non dormivo non
riuscivo a fare l'esame della patente
nel senso proprio studiare per la
patente mi era difficile però detto vale
lo fanno tutti sarà più difficile per me
perché faccio anche youtube quindi c'è
anche questa cosa in più però lo
facciamo ma mio padre mi porta avevo già
il mio primo stipendietto
quindi mio padre roby di togliere
davanti della strada zio prima regola
della patente
mio padre mi porta prima ancora di fare
l'esempio evidente ad una concessionaria
noemi dice sceglila la macchina e lo
guardo e dico no loro lavori già
comprare sceglie la scelta vado li
volevo prendere una nissan juke non lo
avete presente le cose sono poi prima
che avesse piaciuta la lista ingiusto
perché è una macchina
a me non me ne frega na sega delle
macchine mac tra nero che click però mi
piace la juke perché è tipo con la
macchina che sembra tv sud però non è un
sub un po più piccolo quindi una via di
mezzo tra una macchina normale un suv
non troppo grosso come il mio caso
quindi potete dove l'hai questa mi piace
e mio padre ma guarda compra la
la teniamo qua quando quando prendi la
patente
la lavigne a ritirare e io gli ho
risposto guarda papi non me la sento
perché non sono sicuro della scelta
della macchina quindi va beh la prenderò
quando quando prendono la patente non la
voglio prendere prima
provatevi fa sei sicuro e io sì mai
scelta fu più azzeccata
vado a fare l'esame da potente il primo
di monti vado a fare esame faccio tipo 6
errori il limite massimo gli errori che
puoi fare l'esame della patente 4 quanto
errori 6 promosso da cinque in poi sei
bocciato che le faccio 6 e papà non l'ho
passato è vabbè dai succede a tutti nel
senso tante persone non lo passano la
prima botta alle donne una patente anche
perché stessa per la patente ma anche a
culo un punto banche a cui riprendere le
domande che ti capitano va culio alle
volte di capitan le domande sulla catena
della moto
alle volte che ti capita la domanda ti
devi allacciare la cintura prima di
partire
vero ok quindi va anche a culo il mezzo
aveva niente cosa succede arriviamo alle
tavolette di bocciano quindi niente ah
beh ci provo la seconda volta vado la
seconda volta faccio 5 errori quindi uno
in più del solito miri bocciano io parco
a capannori bocciato già lì mi ero
aggirate le balle perchè due volte
mammamia pensa che domandare di una
terza volta alzarmi la mattina i bolli e
di fare prestissimo quindi un casino io
che faccio l'esame della patente ragazzi
è bruttissimo perché tutti quelli che
fanno le tabelle apparente hanno 17 18
anni quindi tutti tutti mi guardano
perché tutti sanno chi sono quindi
stanno così ma poi l'esame non guardare
mai tutti questo dal primo e dal primo
esame che ho fatto nella mia vita la
patente già tutti mi guardavano e che
tutti continuano a guardarmi sempre
sempre quindi quando faccio esame la
patente giuseppe gli occhi addosso
quindi nonostante io l'ho falliscono
falisco anche perché siccome sono una
persona abbastanza timida quando una
persona mi guarda io mi sento irrequieto
quindi non riescono anche a farlo
capitolini ciò anche il suo problema va
bene niente l'ho però fallito e periodo
volte vado la terza volta e succede una
cosa molto simpatica quando tu fai
l'esame della patente succede una cosa
succede che tu devi andare lì a far
esame ma prima devi fare il permesso
scritto il permesso scritto la
fototessera devi andare dal medico fare
l'esame dal medico per la patente perché
sono poi fare l'esame la patente di
ricombinare i documenti portare tutti i
documenti non fate un casino
preparazione come la patente un casinò
oltre che ai spendere soldi per farlo
perché spegne anche soldi per farlo io
sono pure tirchio a quando fallisce
l'esame la prima volta loro ti dicono va
beh torna la seconda non devi di fare
tutti sti casini non devi di andare al
medico di nuovo non devi di andare a
fare i documenti di nuovo non devi fare
niente devi tornare basta perché la
prima volta vuoi fallirla la seconda la
seconda non la puoi fallire perché se
fallisci la seconda volta come a me è
successo devi fare tutto di tornare dal
medico di andare a fare le cose di fare
mille cose
ok quindi la città terza volta che sono
andato lì ho detto va bene ecco mi
faccio l'esame e no non puoi torna a
fare l'esame quindi medico fascicoli
fatto tutto vado a fare l'esame 5 errori
sempre un in più le solite porca vacca
morta però vabbè hai un altro tentativo
mi impegno studio ma perché tu dici ma
che non studi studi un sacco e faccio
anche i quiz sul telefono e ne faccio
tanti e quando faccio questi tutte le
fornire quindi sul telefono di passo
niente va da lì all'esame la quarta
volta quarta volta 4
vado lì all'esame 5 errori sempre un
errore in più sempre un errore in più
del solito sempre lo ripeto il mio
faccio 5 e mi bocciano sempre così
quindi qua quarta bocciatura sempre per
il queen terrore io mi ricordo tra
l'altro anche quali sono gli errori che
ho fatto perché ogni volta che esco dall
esame di coca volo con quella domanda lì
è giusta o sbagliata controllo sbagliata
una volta mi hanno bocciato ad esempio
perché nella domanda diceva su un carro
agricolo possono starci al massimo tre
persone vero falso non mi ricordo messo
tipo falso sono stato bocciato per
questo ci avessi saputo quante persone
possono stare su un carro agricolo a
questo l'avrei la patente e guida ray da
quattro anni ma non lo faccio perché non
so quante persone ci sono su un carro
agricolo un'altra volta vanno ha
bocciato per un altro errore si è così
un altro allora è stato questo tipo
l'esaminatore di guida quando vi fanno
l'esame poi del traffico che non ci sono
mai arrivato quando fai l'esame di guida
l'esaminatore è obbligato a mettersi la
cintura di sicurezza
la mia risposta è stata certo per forza
insomma dopo contro un palo muori quindi
dei mette alla città di sicurezza no la
risposta era no l'esamina terreni da può
non mettersi la città di sicurezza mi
disse tu ti schianti ai 200 all'ora
contro il muro lui muore tu non hai
colpa per una buona può anche non metter
sarà la cintura di sicurezza
io mi ero rotto le balle di fare l'esame
della patente questo a torino lorenzo
quest'uomo che avete visto in questa
bellissima foto mi dice no a zio ma non
lui parla tipo così non lo zio non
esiste mi ha fatto fare l'esame della
patente
qua a milano da
da una persona che ha una scuola guida
che lui conosce benissimo questa persona
mi ha detto guarda facciamo così vieni
alle lezioni di guida io ti faccio
venire quando non le faccio con gli
altri perché le lezioni di guida ci sono
tutti tipo tipo una classe di scuola ci
sono tutti quindi fare lezioni di guida
per me sarebbe come fare l'esame nel
senso che tutti mi fissano quindi
orribile facciamo finta di non sapere
niente ri studiamo i test tutti passati
quasi praticamente il 95 per cento di
test di tutti tutti promosso promosso
promosso promosso promosso promosso
finalmente andiamo all'esame bocciato
vado a fare il quiz dell'esame la
patente
bocciato anche la sesta volta porco
demonio sempre 5 errori e ovviamente non
sei o set che dici mi ka fai schifo 15
ero sempre un in più sempre uno stupido
tipo quelli di prima vado la settima
volta a fare le d'avena patente di nuovo
tutti poi nuove tutte le cose
manco segnato in porta ma in a gioia
vado alla settima volta questa volta non
avevo studiato sono sincero non avevo
studiato perché mi hanno rotto le balle
avevo studiato sei volte ogni volta
studio tutte le volte ogni volta mi
cacciano stato eletto sentita cosa c'è
non studio arrivo fuori dall'esame
faccio un quiz a caso per provare per
vedere come sto messo ragazzi zero
errori 40 risposta che quelle che le
domande del quiz esame sono 40 40
risposte giuste
non era questo e di studiare le sole
cose adesso dipende dalle domande che mi
capitano mi capita la catena della moto
è un casino
lui mi guarda e mi dice grande a posto
entra e fa gli culo entro
secondo me indovinate quanti errori ho
fatto sono meno sapete già ai ragazzi la
vita la vita veramente difficile ho
fatto cinque errori di nuovo se
esistesse un modo per capire quanto buon
senso a una persona oltre che i cartelli
stradali da sapere io lo avrei passato
al primo barra secondo tentativo perché
io quando guida la gente gente che guida
da anni e dico madonna ma come fai
guidare così fai schifo non stare
attaccato al culo di volo davanti che se
quell inchioda ci vai dentro ci sono
tante cose mentalmente che io mi ritengo
molto superiore a tantissime altre
persone che invece hanno la patente
ormai quando vado a fare l'esame della
patente c'è l'esaminatore amici ei
ancora un'altra volta come i carabinieri
io dico che già sono ancora qui ci
vediamo la prossima volta ci vediamo la
consigliamo altabella di ragazzi spero
che video vi sia piaciuto
lasciate un bel like per gli esami uno
per esame quindi 7 like lasciate dai e
vai
ci rivediamo a rompersi o video ad un
prossimo esame ma se volete ve lo faccio
faccio un video gameplay dove faccio
l'esame della patente vi assicuro che li
vengo promosse ai ragazzi
[Musica]